[Music]
in 2021
the payment processing company stripe
became the most valuable us startup
stripe was founded by patrick and john
collison
irish europeans who had a valuable idea
but had to come to the united states
to make it come to life in the same year
the software company uipath also became
regarded
as one of america's fastest growing
companies
uipath was founded by daniel dinez and
marius turca
two romanian europeans who founded their
company in bucharest
but are now headquartered in the us
again and also in the same year
databricks
also became regarded as one of america's
fastest growing companies
although founded by multiple people
databricks was co-founded by ali goatsi
the swede and ion soica or romania
stripe uipath and data bricks are three
examples
of extremely valuable companies that
reflect an overall trend
many driven europeans who are creating
very valuable companies
are doing it in the united states in
fact
i would go as far to say that these
examples reflect the larger problem
that europe loses valuable innovation to
the united states
and europe experiences one of the
largest brain drains
on the planet
[Music]
venture capital allows investors to help
support businesses
that are expected to have future growth
but aren't large enough to generate it
on their own
although europe experiences problems
with developing enough startup companies
to begin with
which is a topic for a later video it's
the later stage funding
where europe primarily experiences a
weakening connection with its founding
companies
late-stage funding for startups is
overwhelmingly provided by the united
states and foreign financiers
this not only shifts responsibility to
investors outside of europe
but it also produces a dynamic where
many european startups
will leave europe in order to go to the
us before receiving later stage funding
[Music]
when european startups exit it's almost
a 50 50 chance
where they'll end up from 2012 to 2016
the startup europe partnership found
that around 44
of european startups were acquired by
u.s companies
and this means that in the same time
period u.s companies
practically acquired as many european
startups as european companies did
an acquisition by a u.s company means
that the original startup's main shares
are bought up
and it is now part of the company that
is skewed towards maximizing the value
of american shareholders
[Music]
immigrants born in europe are over five
times more likely
to have created an innovation in america
compared to the average native born
u.s citizen although it has been
changing
europe has lost many gifted scientists
to the u.s
in the past and there are many graduate
students
who complete their studies outside of
europe and the us
and many of them do not come back
on june 4th 2021 patrick collison
tweeted
the good news is that eu tech is really
starting to bloom
it's only a few characters but he's
completely right
on the 9th of april the european
commission opened up the european
innovation council accelerator
which is tasked with providing
investment and funding for startups by
june of this year
around 2000 companies had applied for
funding which amounted to more than four
times the 1.1 billion euros
the fund could initially give this could
be seen
as both a good and a bad thing there's
clearly a demand for funding
european-based startups
but it's not clear if there will be an
increase in the accelerator's budget
to match that demand for boosting
innovation on european soil
there are however other positive
indications
daniel eck the ceo of spotify pledged
1.2 billion dollars
of his personal fortune to fund deep
tech startups from europe
business to business startups companies
like deliveroo have been outperforming
their american counterparts
and venture capital in europe has been
increasing every year
alongside late stage funding and
european companies
are staying private and independent
longer than ever before
whether europe will eventually become
the most innovative region on the planet
and keep very ambitious europeans on
home soil
is a question that a few college
students with a small youtube channel
cannot tell you however we can tell you
of absolute certainty
that it would be a lie to say that
europe lacks the potential
[Music]
you